in the history of jobs has anybody had a
more misleading job title than Alejandro
mayorkas he is the homeland security
secretary
he has done nothing to enhance but
instead a lot to destroy our homeland
security so if the Border open and he
lied about it millions and millions and
millions of foreign Nationals who
identities we can't confirm have shown
up
by the drug cartels
and come into our country to stay
forever and live at public expense
that's all real
Andy Biggs knows it's really represents
the State of Arizona in the Congress and
he's very frustrated by this he joins us
now Congressman thanks so much for
coming on so you've watched it it's
affected your state and your District
badly hurt both
how do you think the Congress should
respond
well Tucker thanks for having me and I
think that the appropriate response is
to do what the founders said you remove
somebody from Office a public official
from Office who's causing public harm
and violating the public trust and that
is impeachment and I think that is the
uh quite frankly the most pressing
remedy that we we need to Avail
ourselves of with Alejandra mayorkas
what he has done is absolutely in my
opinion it's unconscionable he's
literally attacked the essence of this
country by attacking the geographical
integrity and he's changing uh so much
he's put so many people in danger we've
got terrorists here that would never
have been here we've got criminal gang
members and we've got well over a
million people here we have no idea
anything about their background where
they went because they just got away
into the country because of his policies
I I mean if you can't impeach a Homeland
Security secretary for destroying the
homeland security and allowing an
invasion no exaggeration an invasion to
occur on his watch then what can you
impeach someone for
well I think that's exactly right and
and so people I've had people say but
Andy he didn't commit a real felony and
I said but High crimes means that you're
a public official and that you have
violated the public trust and you need
to be removed look what look at the just
the damage he's done he came in and he
basically got rid of every policy that
was working we had the Yuma sector
Tucker in the last year of trump those
policies would reduce the encounters to
not fewer than 9 000 for the entire
fiscal year
last year that sector alone had over 360
000 encounters and then you you you
stretched that along the entire Southern
border and you're pushing three million
encounters and another million people
who got in uh and got away and those are
the people that are bringing drugs
they're they're human trafficking sex
trafficking they've put this country at
risk and uh quite frankly the first
thing that goes when a country is
actually devolving and is to is is when
you lose your geographical integrity and
secretary mayorskis that's his main job
and he is willfully uh imposed his his
own dangerous policies on us it's not
negligence it's not incompetence it's
willful
yeah and it's a felony he's ignoring the
law the law that Congress passed he's
not elected he's a bureaucrat right
Congressman any Biggs of Arizona great
to see you tonight thank you subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight